okay today I'm going to talk to you
about microscope calculations because
there's two different types of
calculation that we need to do when it
comes to thinking about microscopes so
to begin with I'm just going to draw a
diagram of a microscope so as a quick
recap a microscope is a piece of
equipment that we can use that magnifies
an image now the reason why we want to
magnify something is if it's too small
to see with the naked eye
for example cells so we look down here
the eyepiece lens and if this is the
objective lens so we've got two
different lenses which magnify the image
so first of all here is the eyepiece
lens the bit that you look down we know
that this is this one goes next to your
eye so let's say this one has a
magnification of 10 which means it makes
everything appear 10 times bigger now
the objective lens is this low one here
it's the one that we use to look at the
object so that's why it's called
objective lens now this one normally has
a higher magnification in the eyepiece
lens sometimes it would be maybe up to
14 now microscopes you normally have
more than one objective lens and you can
actually change them round but at any
one time there's only one in use so the
first equation we need to know or the
first kind of bit of maths with
microscopes we need to know it's really
easy to find the total magnification all
that we need to do is multiply the two
different lenses together so the
magnification strength of the two
different lenses so for this particular
example of this microscope I just need
to take my magnification my eyepiece
lens multiply it by the magnification of
the objective lens and nice and simply
that is going to say that this
microscope now is going to have a
magnification 400 so it means that image
was going to appear 400 times bigger
really really simple now the next part
of microscope calculations that we need
to know is this particular equation
triangle now it's nice and easy
to remember it because we can just
remember this I am I am I goes on top
and I'm across the bottom so I just read
it from the top I now what this stands
for is this i stands for image size now
that what that means is how big is the
image that with how big is the image
once viewed not how much how big is it
in real life is a that stands for actual
size so this is how big that the thing
is we're looking at in real life
and finally M stands for magnification
so what that means is how many times is
that image being magnified how many
times bigger is it so let's have a quick
example let's let's see how this works
so let's imagine I've used my microscope
and I've got myself an image which is
this big here so I'm just going to draw
an image now what you might have to do
is let's say we're trying to find how
big this this thing and this could be a
cell for example but how big is this
thing in real life so what I what I've
got here is the size of my image and
let's say I'm using this microscope here
so that's my magnification so the first
thing that I need to do is I need to see
how big this image is so I could just
measure this with a ruler so this here
is about six point six centimeters in
diameter so what I then need to do is I
then need to use this equation triangle
to find the actual size so just like
normal whenever I use an equation
triangle I cover the thing that I'm
looking for so I'm looking for the
actual size so I'm going to cover that
up so what I'm going to need to do is
I'm going to need to take my image size
which is six point six centimeters and
divide it by the magnification for this
particular microscope remember because
the eyepiece lens
and objective and 40 the total
magnification is 400 so all I'm doing is
6.6 divided by 400 in order to find my
actual size so then I just need to do
this on a calculator six point six
divided by 400 which equals zero point
zero one six five centimeters now what
they might ask you to do with probably
probably ask you to do is you might have
to convert this to different units for
example micrometers but I'm going to
show that in a different video so just
to summarize to find the total
magnification you simply multiply
multiply the magnification of the
eyepiece lens by the multiple check mark
sorry by the magnification of the
objective lens and in order to find the
image size exercise of magnification you
use this equation triangle of I thank
you very much